[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation modulation of the
cspg receptor ptp sigma to enhance neuro
repair this webinar is part of the 10th
annual neuroscience virtual conference
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots so let's get
started before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to first
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our live chat feature
during the presentation you can find
this live chat located at the right of
your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during
this presentation to do so simply type
them in to the ask a question box and
click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that help desk located at the bottom of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby and finally as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on that continuing education
credits link located at the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker dr mark depaul
the director of research at nervegen
pharma for a complete biography of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the left of your screen dr dabal
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
oh thank you susie for the introduction
and thank you lab roots for organizing
today's meeting and for the invite to
speak
today i'm very excited to introduce to
you the company nervegen and our
technology that we believe can
treat any type of nervous system damage
whether it is occurring from a traumatic
injury such as spinal cord injury due to
disease processes such as stroke or
alzheimer's disease
or in the peripheral such as peripheral
nerve injuries
so a little bit about the company so we
are developing a brand new class of
therapeutics targeting a brand new
receptor
which i'll go into in subsequent slides
and this
new class of therapeutics is being
developed to target repair following
nervous system damage
the therapeutic that we are developing
is called mvg291 and it targets the
receptor protein tyrosine phosphatase
sigma or ptp sigma and ptb sigma has
been shown to be involved in many
different repair processes such as
remyelination regeneration and
plasticity it also has effects within
the immune system anatomy activation
and
using our compound we have investigated
several different models of nervous
system damage that and have resulted in
clinically relevant improvements in many
different functional areas including
gross motors function sensory function
autonomic function and cognitive
function
so we are a clinical stage biotech
company we are currently in a phase one
trial in which we're investigating our
compounds in healthy volunteers which
began last year and we'll read out later
this year
and we plan to begin three
phase two trials in spinal cord injury
alzheimer's disease and multiple
sclerosis
so now i'd like to go a little bit into
what our technology is and how it's able
to enhance repair following different
types of nervous system damage
so our technology is based around the
discovery that can join sulfate protein
glycans or cstgs are present in the
brain and in the spinal cord and inhibit
nervous system repair
cspgs are an extracellular matrix
molecule that consists of a core protein
which is shown here in yellow and then
off of the core protein are the sulfated
sugar side chains and these sugar side
chains which are shown here in red are
the inhibitory parts of the protein
cspgs
are known to have several biological
functions in the
healthy adult individual
first they play a structural component
in many different body parts they are
major components of cartilage and it's
one of the reasons why cartilage is
not innervated very well both from a
nervous system standpoint and a vascular
standpoint because the cspg these cspgs
help inhibit that type of innervation
and growth into the cartilage tissue
giving him into its role within the
central nervous system injury
it also plays a role in early
development where
cspgs will act as corridors to help
guide neurons and axons away from areas
where they shouldn't be and towards
areas to where they should be
and then in the adult nervous system
they play a role in a structure called
the perineurinal net which is pictured
here on the right
a perineural nut is this lattice-like
structure that surrounds
the synapses and dendrites and cell
bodies of many different neurons and
helps maintain synaptic integrity
and i'll go into a little bit how the
neural net plays a role in recovery and
how it inhibits plasticity of the
central nervous system
and so those are the roles of conjoined
sulfate proteoglycans in the normally
functioning individual but also has a
role following nervous system damage so
cspgs are upregulated around areas of
damage in the forming scar known as the
glial scar that occurs now down at the
bottom two examples of this occurring uh
the first is with a uh lysol lenses
model or lpc model of demyelination
which is detergent is administered to
the central nervous system and it breaks
down the myelin
and you can see
cspgs are labeled in red in the animal
that receives the lpc injection there's
a very large upper regulation of cspgs
around the area of demyelination
and the sham control which did not
receive the the detergent uh received a
control injection of saline uh but you
can see in the middle of the image there
there's actually an up regulation of
cspgs where the needle uh penetrated the
central nervous system in order to
deliver that vehicle so even very small
injuries within the cns can cause a
upregulation of cspgs around areas of
damage
and they're also found around areas of
damage due to neurodegenerative
processes for example the example have
here is an alzheimer's plaque and a
patient
the white at the very center of the
image is a plaque and then the dark
black around it are cspgs which surround
the plaque
um now cspgs are also up regulated
following injury away from these sites
of injury within the peri-neuronal nets
so for example if you injure your spinal
cord in the thoracic area which is
around the area of your rib cages
there's an upregulation of cspgs in the
cervical area which is by your neck or
in the lumbar area which is more by your
belly
and so this is
a little bit separate from what is
observed within the glial scar
where the cspgs are component of the
scarp these cspgs are upregulated around
the paranormal nets which which surround
synapses and cell bodies and help to
maintain those synaptic connections
so by upregulation around cspgs within
the injury site
csvgs can inhibit regeneration around
areas of damage and by upregulation of
cspgs within the period neural net away
from the areas of damage csvgs inhibit
plasticity that could
potentially allow the central nervous
system to reorganize itself to bring
about functional recovery
and i want to take a little bit of time
to introduce this idea of plasticity and
the perineural net because it's central
to understanding how our compound works
um well first actually i do want to
describe cspgs in the context of the
scar and developmental biology um in
this image we have what we what is
called a spot assay
and for those of you that drink coffee
if you ever spilled a drop of coffee on
your desk and let it dry the coffee
dries in a gradient where the rim is
very highly concentrated then as you
move towards the center of the rim it
becomes less and less concentrated it's
a very nice gradient of coffee something
similar happens following an injury in
the central nervous system where you
have very high concentration of cspgs at
the epicenter of the injury then as you
move away from the injury the cspgs
begin to decrease
and this gradient causes a certain
response in neurons that are
regenerating into that inhibitory rim as
opposed to during development where
cspgs are laid down more of a wall where
it's either there or not there
and by
drying cspgs on a cover slip they dry
very similar to how a coffee drop dries
on your desk and so we're able to model
both the developmental display of cspgs
to axons as well as the
glial scar or the injury display of the
gradient to axons
and so in this image the uh the neurons
that are cultured at the top of the
image um
approach the spot as similar to what is
observed during development and those
neurons that are plated at the bottom of
the image
approach the spot in the gradient
fashion so the the spot is outlined in
the dotted white line there
and i have a couple arrows pointing at a
neuron that's outside the spot that's
growing towards the spine and you can
see the axon which is at the arrowhead
as it approaches the cspg wall it turns
and grows alongside of it which is very
different than how the neurons that are
approaching the cspgs from within the
spot itself the neurons that are
approaching the cspgs within the spot
they become stuck and embedded within
the cspg gradients and they become
dystrophic and they will remain embedded
and stuck in that cspg gradient
indefinitely and this is very
reminiscent to what we observe is
happening following an injury within
animals as well as people where
regenerating axons becomes stuck within
the gradient of cspgs and become
dystrophic and you can observe these
dystrophic axons in the lesion
environment decades after the injury has
occurred
so cspgs can also inhibit plasticity of
the central nervous system uh the
example i have here is a neuron on the
left is trying to make a synapse with
the second order neuron there on the
right so it's able to extend an axon and
get very close to that neuron but due to
the paranormal nets which surrounds the
second order neurons cell body and
dendrites the axon is never able to
penetrate the paranormal net and make
contact with the second order neuron in
order to form a functional synapse
there's a couple different ways we can
remove the perineural net there's an
enzyme called chondroitinase which is a
bacterial derived enzyme that degrades
cspgs and if you degrade the cspgs of
the period neural nets that is
sufficient to allow the neuron access to
the second order neuron to make a
functional synapse and so this concept
is known as plasticity the rewiring of
the central nervous system to bring
about a novel function
and it can be used in times of injury
to allow rewiring of the central nervous
system around the injury sites to allow
the information to flow around areas of
damage
as i have example here
in injuries in this case it's a spinal
cord injury
where there's a damaged neuron and no
spinal cord injuries are incomplete
meaning that there are some neurons that
are able to bypass the injury site and
so by enhancing plasticity we can allow
the damaged neurons to make new
connections with neurons that are able
to bypass the injury site and allow the
spare neurons that are able to project
below the level of injury to make new
connections to neurons that were
de-innervated due to the injury site and
through this process known as plasticity
we can reroute information around the
injury site to bring about functional
recovery
tspgs have been shown to be
pathologically
involved and associated with several
different diseases and conditions in
people
some of the examples that we're
interested in as a company include
alzheimer's disease multiple sclerosis
spinal cord injury smoke stroke and
traumatic brain injury
and in all these cases there are
examples that cspgs are pathologically
involved in human patients
now the inhibitory role of cspgs has
been known for quite some time
this is a little bit of a dead slide but
i want to go over the timeline of
regeneration failure within the central
nervous system so back in the early
1900s ramone cahall identified that
axons within the central nervous system
failed to regenerate
and it wasn't until uh
the late 80s that
cspgs were appreciated to be a major
player in regeneration failure they're
first shown to be a major component of
the glial scar in spinal cord injury in
the late 80s as well as a prominent
component of perineurinal net
and then throughout the 90s cspgs were
identified in a number of
neurodegenerative diseases including
alzheimer's disease parkinson's
to name a few multiple sclerosis as well
and then around the late 90s
investigators started utilizing an
enzyme called chondroitinase which has
the ability to digest csp chips and they
found that when they digested cspgs
they're able to bring about recovery in
a number of different uh conditions of
the central nervous system the first
being spinal cord injury which is shown
in 2001.
so this research carried on for the for
the next decade or so and it wasn't
until 2009 that the receptor mediating
many of these negative effects was
finally discovered as ptp sigma or
protein tyrosine phosphatase sigma
so the effects of cspgs were known for
over 20 years before the receptor
mediating these effects were known
and now that the receptor was identified
we now had a target that we could a drug
to be able to modulate this activity and
and inhibit the effects of cspgs
and so my team and i um
went together and developed the
predecessor to nerve genes technology
which we published in 2015
uh known as mvg291
and is the foundation of what nervegens
technology is based on
and so now i want to take a couple
moments to describe the receptor and the
biology that it's involved in
so ptp sigma is a trans membrane
receptor it has an extracellular
component that will bind to
proteoglycans the examples i gave here
is heparin sulfate pro-glycan and can
joint sulfate proteoglycan
and based on the proteoglycan family it
binds to it either has an activation
effect on the receptor or an inhibition
effect on the receptor and the
activation and inhibition of the
receptor is dependent on the
dimerization status of the receptor when
cspgs bind to the receptor it causes the
receptor to monomerize which reveals a
phosphatase pocket and activates
downstream second messenger systems that
inhibit accidental growth such as
railway and it inhibits growth
associated pathways which can activate
growth such as akt and irk
so p2p sigma is able to signal through a
second messenger system to control
general growth related
response in the cell
and it also has effects locally within
the growth cone itself
the example i have outlined here is the
effects on autophagy
so autophagy is the cell's ability to
recycle proteins and it's needed to
recycle these proteins in order to make
new proteins to continue the growth
process
if you halt autophagy the cell is no
longer able to recycle these proteins
and in order for autophagy to occur the
autophagosome which contains the
components that need to be recycled need
to fuse with the lysosome in order to
degrade the proteins this step is
dependent on a protein called cortactin
which is a direct substrate of ptp sigma
when pcp sigma is activated through
binding of cspgs it causes cortectin to
be dephosphorylated and inactivated
which causes a halt in the fusion step
of autophagy
which causes then the growth code to
become dystrophic
and so uh this slide is meant to
illustrate that pgp sigma has both a
global uh second messenger system effect
on the cell growth associated pathways
as well as local effects on uh pathways
that are regulating the growth cone at
the growing axon tip
also similar to cspgs p2b sigma is also
upregulated following injury
the two examples i have here one is a
traumatic injury and spinal cord injury
you can appreciate around the lesion
area which is in panel b on the on the
left two panels there's a high up
regulation of p2p sigma around the area
of damage
um and then an a uh which is far away
from the lesion you can see a much lower
expression of the wrist of the receptor
so ptp similar is expressed at basal
levels and when it comes to contact with
a damaged environment it up regulates
uh this is also true for
neurodegenerative diseases and the case
i have here is an eae model of multiple
sclerosis which uses in the immune
system to attack myelin sheaths within
the central nervous system and we see a
very large increase of pgp sigma within
the cns in these eae mice specifically
within oligodendrocytes
so how do we modulate the receptor
the receptor is uh as i mentioned before
the receptor is inactivated when it's in
its dimerized form
and part of the regulatory domain is
this domain known as the wedge domain
that's responsible for activation and
inhibition of the receptor
so our drug takes nature's method of
modulating the receptor the wedge domain
and attaches a self-penetrating tat
domain to the switch domain and so we uh
so our drug is a peptide memetic of the
wedge domain of the ptp signal receptor
attached to a cell penetrating peptide
sequence and this allows the
peptide to pass through the blood-brain
barrier as well as through cell
membranes to allow the drug to enter the
cell to elicit its effects on ptp sigma
and we find that when we add our drug to
cells we reverse the effects of csbg
signaling for example
csbgs cause an increase in row a and a
decrease in akt and erg signaling and
when we treat the cells with our
compounds we inhibit railway activation
and increase akt and erg which leads to
an increase in axonal growth
remyelination and plasticity
now throughout this talk i'll be talking
about a few different molecules um they
are all very similar
mvg291-r is our rodent version of the uh
compound it is a peptide-memetic of the
rodent wedge domain mvg291 is the human
mathematic of the wedge domain in our
clinical trial drug
the two drugs differ by a single amino
acid and we've tested both versions
against human cells and both versions
against rodent cells they both have the
same pharmacological effect
in the pre-clinical research a number of
academic labs have published research
using our compounds and they refer to it
as isp or intracellular sigma peptide
and so if you look at the literature our
drug is described as ist and there's a
few grafts in here that label it as isp
and
going back to the coffee drop experiment
which i showed you a couple slides ago
you can see the effects of the neurons
when we apply our compounds to that same
study
so at the top here in the left panel is
the same slide i showed you a couple
slides ago where the neurons are
inhibited from crossing the inhibitory
gradient when we add the compound to the
neurons in the spot assay the neurons
are able to ignore those cspgs and grow
across that inhibitory rim ignoring
those cspgs
so as i mentioned before our drug has
multiple modes of action
we believe that plasticity is a major
driver of the effects that we're seeing
we also observe significant axonal
regeneration around areas of damage and
enhancements in remyelination and these
are the three topics i wish to talk on
about today in more detail but we do
have other effects on the innate immune
system as well as on stem cell biology i
will hold those off for another
discussion
so
ptp sigma modulation
using our compound has been tested in
several different animal models and has
led to clinically relevant functional
recovery across many different areas of
function
so we've investigated our compound in
spinal cord injury peripheral nerve
injury multiple sclerosis models of
optic neuritis stroke and cardiac
ischemia and we've seen improvements in
motor function sensory function
cognition and autonomic function it's an
autonomic function specifically looking
at respiration
bladder function and cardiac pacemaking
i'll go into a couple of these studies
and show you data on how exactly our
compound is eliciting the effects to
bring about this recovery
the first examples i want to give are
examples in which we'll show
enhancements in plasticity and
regeneration
so an ideal model to investigate this is
the ischemic stroke model in which we
elicit a stroke in one half of the brain
which is identified there by the
gray area of the brain taken out known
as the infarct zone
and in this model only one half of the
brain is damaged the other half remains
intact
and the area of the brain that we damage
sends axons down through the brain stem
into the spinal cord and innervates
areas of the spinal cord so this so the
blue tissue section you see down below
is part of the cervical spinal cord
and we can see how the non-damaged
neurons respond to our compound in an
injury environment by labeling those
neurons using a label in this case bda
and so we can inject bda into the intact
side of the brain and then follow the
axons as they grow and regenerate or or
enhance their plasticity
so what we see is uh when we stain for
the
non-damaged axons
we see
across the corpus of a significant
amount of neurons or axons that are
regenerating or sprouting across the
corpus callosum
which is the high wave in which the
axons travel from one side of the brain
to the other
and then if we looked around the
peri-infarct zone we see a significant
amount of
sprouting from those regenerating axons
around the peri-infarct zone and those
are quantified over here on the left
and we see a very similar sprouting
within the spinal cord itself
so within the spinal cord the
the area of the brain projects to the
contralateral side of the spinal cord uh
and due to the damage the contralateral
side of the spinal cord is de-innervated
because that area of the brain no longer
is able to set those projections down
due to the stroke
and so in response to our drug treatment
the intact side of the brain is able to
send axons across the midline of the
spinal cord and innervate areas that
were de-innervated due to the stroke
and so this is a really elegant example
of what i mean by plasticity and the
ability of the brain to rewire itself in
response to injury to bring about
functional recovery in areas that were
de-innovative due to the injury
and these
sprouting effects do lead to functional
benefits so a couple examples i have
here is in sensory motor recovery in an
assay called the adhesive removal test
and this is looking at longitudinally
through the four weeks of treatment
beginning at negative one this prior to
treatment and in this test a piece of
tape is placed on a rodent's pop and the
rodent needs to be able to feel the tape
and remove that piece of tape and the
amount of time it takes to remove the
tape is quantified
prior to injury the animals are very
efficient at removing the tape and then
after injury there's a significant
decrease in their ability to move the
tape treating the animals with their
compound you see a significant
improvement in their ability to remove
that tape indicating they've recovered
sensory motor function
the second example i want to give is an
example of the cognitive recovery we
observe in this
stroke model
using a study or using an assay called
the barnes maze the barnes maze is very
similar with the more well-known morse
water maze but it's a dry version of
that where an animal is placed on a
table that has many different holes cut
out on the table and one of the holes
contains a platform that the animal is
able to hide to to get away from the
bright lights of the room on the walls
are different visual cues so the animal
is able to orient itself and order many
trials the animal remembers where that
hole is and is able to find that hole
very quickly
because of stroke these animals have a
large deficit and they make a number of
errors due to
being unable to remember and with our
compound we're able to enhance their
ability to remember where the hole is
and they're able to find that hole much
quicker making fewer errors
suggesting that our compound is
enhancing the ability to remember
in this essay
we've observed this sort of sprouting in
many different neuron types including uh
serotonin sprouting and sensory neurons
um from the
dorsal ganglion cells within motor
neurons um auto autonomic neurons
especially sympathetic neurons
perpetual spinal neurons and then the
examples i gave above are cortical
spinal and cortical cortical
the second example i want to give is
some data following spinal cord injury
in which we had a mid-thoracic spinal
cord injury and the top
longitudinal sections are showing
serotonin staining
now serotonin regions are found within
the brain and they need to set axons
down the spinal cord a injury in the
spinal cord will disrupt that the
serotonin tracts and anything below the
level of injury no longer has serotonin
sprouting and this can be visualized in
the images at top where the rostral
which means the head is to the left and
you can see bright green staining from
serotonin that as you move past the
lesion which is found in the middle of
the
image to the caudal regions which is by
the tail you see a significant decrease
in the amount of serotonin staining in
the vehicle treated which is up top our
compound was able to significantly
enhance the amount of serotonin below
the level of injury and to better image
that i have a couple representative
images from the lumbar spinal cord in a
cross section and you can appreciate
that in the naive animal there's a lot
of serotonin within the gray matter
which is that butterfly looking shape
in the cross section and which is
labeled in g
the vehicle which is
saline has almost no serotonin
innervation in the lumber section with
our compound mvg-291r we're able to
significantly increase the amount of
serotonin sprouting in that lumbar area
of the spinal cord showing that we're
enhancing regeneration and sprouting of
the serotonin systems
and similar to stroke we see behavioral
improvements in our spinal cord injury
studies as well
and in this study we um injured 29 um
rodents and 21 of the 29 responded with
some sort of recovery whether that be in
locomotion or bladder recovery
some animals recovered locomotion some
animals recovered bladder and some
animals recovered both the type of
injury was a contusion injury which is a
variable it's it's a
it's not a very discrete injury so there
could be different populations of
neurons damaged which would allow
different groups different neurons
responding to our treatment which is why
we likely saw
some benefits in in locomotion in some
animals and
some benefits in bladder and other
animals and other animals recovered both
uh but the take home here is that the
vast majority responded in in some
degree or another with our treatment
and the type of improvement that we're
seeing is it's actually quite
substantial
this is a graph of the locomotor
improvement that we're observing
and in this graph a zero is complete
paralysis and 21 is a perfectly walking
animal prior to injuries all the animals
are working are walking perfectly and
then following the injury there's a
significant decrease in ability to walk
anything below a nine is
movement of the hind limbs without
weight support at a score of nine the
animals are able to begin bearing
weights at ten they begin walking
and at 13 they begin having frequent
coordination and so you can appreciate
that in the vehicle tree that these
animals on average were not even able to
bear weight and then with our treatments
these animals were able to not only bear
weight and walk their walking was
coordinated and they started showing
some fine motor movements such as
placing their paw parallel to their body
and being able to lift their tail off
the ground while walking
and to give you a visual on what this
looks like i have a video of these two
groups on the left will be the control
group in which the rat climbs up a
ladder and on the right
to appropriately place
the
um it's able unable to properly place
the paws on the rungs
now in the treatment group this animal
is able to use the time legs able to
support weight that is able to make
contact with the rungs appropriately the
animal is not perfect walking you may
have seen it slip there so there is some
room for improvement but it's vastly
better than what has been observed in
the non-treatment group
up next i want to show you some data in
which
next i want to show you some data in
which we
show that our company is able to enhance
remyelination and this obviously will
have implications for
multiple sclerosis
currently in multiple sclerosis there
are some
really fantastic drugs that have come
out to
inhibit damage and inhibit the immune
attacks from attacking the myelin
sheaths
however if
an attack occurs there's damage that
occurs and there are no drugs to
currently repair the damage that occurs
and so we believe that our drug can work
with multiple sclerosis by repairing the
damage that has occurred not necessarily
inhibiting the attacks but repairing any
damage that has already occurred
and this can be done in two ways first
obviously multiple sclerosis there's a
deficit in
pollination we can enhance the ability
of opcs to migrate to the areas of
demolition and for oligodendrocytes to
myelinate the axons and secondly in
multiple sclerosis it's not just a
disease of myelin but there's actual
axonal damage and neuron damage as well
and so with our drug we can either
enhance the regeneration of those
damaged axons to allow them to
re-intervene distal targets or we can
enhance plasticity to allow the central
nervous system to reorganize itself
around the areas of damage to bring
about recovery
the two examples i want to give here are
two different models of demyelination
the first is using an lpc model in which
we inject a detergent into the dorsal
column it was very similar to the image
i showed in my introduction
and 21 days post administration of the
compounds there's still significant
demyelination within the dorsal column
of the spinal cord and placebo treated
animals
whereas our compound is able to
completely remyelinate the spinal cord
following 21 days of administration
similarly in an ee model which uses in
the immune system to attack myelin
sheaths within the spinal cord we see a
significant amount of remyelination in
those treated with mvg291 or as labeled
here isp
uh we did this we measured this in a few
different ways uh the top example was
using an antibody approach standing for
myelin based protein and we also
investigated this using electron
microscopy to look at the actual
myelin sheaths themselves as they
surround the axons and what we
identified was there's an enhancement to
the number of myelinated axons per field
of vision
and the myelin sheaths were much thicker
in the treated groups versus the
non-treated group which is measured by
the g ratio
the g ratio it takes the diameter of the
axon and divides it by the thickness of
the myelin so the thicker the myelin the
smaller the g ratio and what we observed
is that we have a much thicker myelin
around axons that were treated with our
compounds than in the axons in the
animals that were treated with the
vehicle control
suggesting that our compound is
enhancing the remyelination in the eae
model
this enhancement to remyelination does
lead to clinical recovery as well
this isn't this graph is showing the
clinical recovery of the animals and in
this graph zero is a perfectly
uh fine non-diseased animal and a four
is uh death
um and in order to
elicit this model you inoculate the
animal with
with agents to activate the immune
system at day zero it takes about 10
days to 12 days for the immune system to
ramp up its attack on the central
nervous system before the symptoms begin
to occur
we tried intervening at two different
time points either at the onset of
symptoms which is indicated by the red
line at about day 10
or at the pika symptoms which is
indicated by the green line
at about day 16.
both intervention at the onset of
symptoms or at the pika symptoms led to
repair of the central nervous system and
a significant increase in the recovery
in these animals
but one thing i do want to point your
attention to is that for the
treatment group that was treated at the
onset of the symptoms
they still developed the disease and so
if you look at the slope of the lines
their deficits peaked at the same height
as the vehicle or those that received
the treatment at later periods
suggesting that we're not affecting
the disease process itself but what we
are doing is repairing the damage
done by the disease
and to give you an idea of the type of
recovery that we are observing in these
animals i have a video here this video
is going to go through time in which we
show
the animal's recovery over the course of
and on the right is the treated group
and so you'll appreciate i had after
about 10 days
the animal begins to walk a little bit
um there's some movement of the hind
limbs that i've seen in the treatment
group versus non-treatment group in 15
days they begin to weigh bear begin
waddling much better walking than what
is observed in the isp or in the
non-treated group
20 days even better walking they are
starting to place their foot parallel to
the body um still not perfect but
they're able they're quite mobile now
and able to bear weight
25 days even better walking now both
feet are being placed parallel good
weight support there's some tone in the
tail suggesting that it has some trunk
strength strength as well
and so these are the types of recoveries
that we're seeing in the eae model
following delivery of our compound
and so we've demonstrated revelation in
multiple disease models not just in
multiple sclerosis like models but in
several other disease models as well
including in spinal cord injury and as
well as in peripheral nerve injuries as
well we have effects on schwann cells
we're able to enhance their ability to
remyelinate peripheral nervous system
tissue as it regenerates through areas
of damage
lastly i want to talk about
our thoughts regarding p2b sigma and
cspgs and alzheimer's disease now we've
not investigated our compounds in an
animal model of alzheimer's disease yet
those are ongoing but we do have data
surrounding cspgs at ptp sigma's role in
alzheimer's disease
that make us feel confident about
approaching this disease
first i want to show you that all cspgs
are associated with cognitive impairment
in patients and so this is looking at
patients brains
and either
those that exhibit no cognitive
impairment mild cognitive impairments or
those that have been diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease and it can
appreciate that as your cognitive
ability decreases the amount of cspgs
found within the brain increases
so we believe that our compound can
improve alzheimer's disease through many
of the same mechanisms that has been
shown to improve
uh following stroke and spinal cord
injury and and multiple sclerosis so by
enhancing axonal regeneration
myelination and plasticity and there may
also be a component there on the
enhanced clearance of a beta
through
microglial
interactions
so in a ptp sigma knockout mouse that
was crossed with a a beta over
expression mouse in a model of
alzheimer's we observe the mouse that
has ptp sigma knocked out to have much
lower
levels of a beta and that's true for
both a beta 40 as well as 42 we see a
significant decrease in the a beta load
in those animals that are that have p2b
sigma missing from their genome
and by knocking out pgp sigma you're
able to enhance the cognitive ability of
these alzheimer's mice as well and in
this example here the white bars are
wild-type mice these are non-diseased
mice the red bars are the mice that have
alzheimer's disease and the blue bars
are the mice that have alzheimer's
disease with ptp sigma knocked out and
in these two examples i'm showing you
improvements in spatial memory uh
through the y mace test as well as their
ability to
recognize novel objects through the
novel object recognition test in both
these cases were able to
significantly improve the
cognitive ability of these mice by
knocking out ptp sigma
uh cspgs are also involved in the
pathology of alzheimer's disease and in
the case here i have an example of where
cspgs were degraded in the periodontal
cortex of an alzheimer's mouse using the
enzyme can droid base
digestion of cspgs led to a decrease in
the amount of eight beta found within
that area in the brain suggesting that
cspgs may be preventing a beta from
being cleared
which makes sense in the introduction i
showed you a slide which showed that in
human patients a beta plaques are
surrounded by cspgs and we know that
cspgs inhibits
cells in general from being able to
migrate through that area so one working
hypothesis that cspgs may be preventing
the clearance of a beta plaques from
brains by their effects on microglia and
macrophages
digestion of cspgs leads to lower plaque
level
as well as increases in cognitive
performance uh so i have example here a
uh
csp detroit nasa injected into an a beta
model of alzheimer's disease in which
we're able to restore
the
uh fear memories of these mice
and in this example here the wild type
non-disease aren't blue and the diseased
are in red uh chabc is the
chondroitinase mouse
that was delivered with joint base and
then pen is a penicillinase which
digests penicillin which is not
endogenously found in these animals so
this is
a negative control and you can see that
kedroid nasa was able to significantly
improve the ability of these mice to
remember fearful memories
so that's an a beta model
we also have evidence in town models
that were able to enhance
cognitive ability by degrading cspgs so
it's not specific for a beta but it's
specific but it could enhance memory
across several different models of
alzheimer's disease and in this case i
have the example of a towel model of
alzheimer's disease which were able to
restore the ability of novel object
recognition in those alzheimer's disease
mice by digesting cfpgs
so
cspgs and p2p sigma play a role in
normal everyday cognition in wild type
mice as well it's not just in disease
states and in this slide i'll go over a
couple examples of what happens to our
memories when you either digest cspgs or
you knock out ptp sigma
the first example
we digested cspgs um in a wild type
mouse and looked at their ability to
recognize novel objects in the wild type
mouse those that were not treated with
chondroitinase and did not have their
cspgs digested begin to forget about the
novel object about 24 hours after
they've been introduced to the novel
object
the animals in which we digested the
cspgs were able to remember the novel
object for longer periods of time out to
48 hours in this example showing that
cspgs are playing a role in memory
consolidation and recall
similarly in ptb sigma null mice and
otherwise wild-type backgrounds we see
enhancements in
novel object recognition compared to
wild type in
mice that have the pgp sigma gene
completely knocked out
we also see improvements in novel object
recognition
in mice that have one working copy of
ptp sigma so half of insufficiency is
also sufficient in order to elicit a
cognitive improvement in these otherwise
wild-type mice
and so this data suggests that cspgs and
ptp sigma play a role in memory
consolidation and recall in normal
wild-type mice
uh so i want to move on to let you know
where we are as a company in terms of
our clinical development
so we are currently undergoing a phase
one clinical trial in healthy volunteers
we have completed our single ascending
dose through six different cohorts
to date the single sending dose has been
very successful and well tolerated and
we have now began our multiple ascending
dose
and for the multiple assigning dose we
will be administering the compounds for
14 days
and um at the doses identified here
uh we're beginning our multiple setting
dose at a higher dose level as justified
by the data that we received with by the
single sending dose study
to give you an idea of what that data
looks like i have down here the
pharmacokinetic data that shows a very
nice dose
response to the
bioavailability of the compounds
and this pharmacopharma kinetic data or
pk data is a measurement of the
blood levels of the compound and we see
that a very nice distribution of the
compound into the blood following a
subcutaneous administration and the pk
values are in line or better than what
we observed in the rata which is very
exciting for us in terms of translating
this to humans we have longer half-lifes
in the humans than we do in rodents
which is
fantastic and similarly the levels at
which we are administering
are at or have exceeded the human
equivalent doses we have used for
efficacy studies in rodents and over
here on the on the right the amount of
compound we've administered through the
various different models of nervous
system damage and preclinical models and
where we are in terms of our clinical
trials and so we are well within or
above the therapeutic range already
identified in rodents and i will say
that uh tests
in the rodent efficacy models
have not been tested at higher doses so
we do not know what the true sealing
effect is of this compound but it does
have a very large range of effect aegis
doses as small as 0.01 milligrams per
kilogram up to 0.32 milligrams per
kilogram
and then our activities for the next
year as i mentioned we are in currently
in a phase one clinical trial uh with
our multiple ascending dose and then we
will begin a phase two clinical trials
of spinal cord injury alzheimer's
disease and multiple sclerosis at the
end of this year early next year
uh preclinically we are currently
investigating our compound in chronic
spinal cord injury and we also have some
ongoing alzheimer's uh studies
to test our compounds and the stroke
data which i presented in this
presentation
is under review at a journal and will be
published shortly so we have a lot of
really good data in that paper up and
coming many of which i did not touch on
today but we're very excited for this
publication to come out
and with that i will be happy to answer
any questions
thank you dr depaul for that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar and if
you have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen so let's get started we
have some great questions
coming in
and
our first question
do you envision nvg 291 to replace a
standard of care
or accompany it
a good question
so we do not believe that our compound
is modifying the disease process what
we're really targeting is the repair
falling damage of a disease process and
so we believe that our compound can be
used in combination with current
standard of care
uh in the clinic for example multiple
sclerosis has some really efficient
standard of care drugs which are able to
quite effectively prevent the immune
system attacks to the central nervous
system however there are
cases in which the immune system is
still able to attack and causes damage
the current standard of care does not
address the damage that is caused it
only
is only there to prevent the damage from
occurring in the first place and so we
think we could accompany standard of
care in most disease cases and would not
be competing with the current standard
of care
thank you so much
and is there a
um
could this be applied to tbi
absolutely this is something we are very
interested in investigating is traumatic
brain injury uh so we're um
it's not part of our core
indications as you can imagine our
technology has the potential to treat
a huge huge array of different
indications
for historical reasons in which what the
data have supports we have
chosen to first focus on spinal cord
injury
multiple sclerosis and alzheimer's
disease but we're actively
approaching labs and other sources of
funding to investigate non-core areas
with tbi being at the very top of that
list
thank you now dr depaul have
cspgs and ptp sigma been found to play a
role in addiction
uh that's really interesting uh so cspgs
have been known to play a role in
addiction
so their the paranormal net is found in
areas of the brain that deal with
addiction and it has been shown that if
you digest the cspgs in those areas of
the brain you can allow reorganization
that could potentially
alleviate the addictive
behaviors uh how ptv sigma plays a role
in this has not been investigated so
we're unsure if pgp sigma is playing a
role in this or if it's cspg is in
general in the paranormal nets but there
is
uh data to suggest that cspgs are
playing a role in the addiction
thank you and again i want to thank our
audience for these great questions
coming in
is there another or other receptor on
ptp stigma that could regulate repair in
neurodegenerative
damage and if so
have these been considered in your
research
that's that's a great question so p2b
sigma is part of a larger family of
receptors known as the lar family
receptors and includes three different
receptors lar ptp sigma and ptp delta
and all three of these do respond to
csvgs in to some regard and we've
developed compounds against
them and we've tested our compounds
against these receptors and ptb sigma
was found to be the most potent of the
three
so that's within the lar family
receptors there are other receptors as
well that have been known to interact
with cspgs
such as uh
uh such as the noga receptor
and
a few others uh that were identified
prior to pgp sigma but the potency and
the concentrations needed to elicit the
effect could not adequately explain the
effects of cspgs on the cells
it wasn't until ptb sigma was discovered
and by inhibiting it you you observe the
effects of cells onto spgs that it was
appreciated that ptp sigma and the lar
family are likely contributing to many
of the inhibitory effects that cspgs are
eliciting
thank you so much now do you see this
working to improve smell and taste
dysfunction due to covid19 infection
great question
that yes that is a great question it's
something we've discussed um internally
as well um it's potentially
we don't know exactly what is causing
the dysfunction to taste and smell in
covid and it is
often spontaneously
return uh and so if it's actually due to
some sort of nerve damage uh there
potentially could be a way for a
compound to enhance recovery of smell
and taste or other types of brain damage
following covenanting uh we just don't
know about and not know enough about the
type of damage and the mechanisms that
play to
uh answer that adequately but it is
definitely within the realm of our
technology's capabilities
now dr depaul in the adult brain a brain
plasticity is a good or bad process and
it is ideal to have a high or low number
of perineural
nets in the adult brain
i'm not sure if that was
i think i've read about decreasing pnns
in the adult brain but that seems
counterintuitive if pnns are protective
if
cspgs inhibit adult brain plasticity is
that a bad thing
so that's a very good question and
there's a lot to unpack here
well first of all our drug does not
digest cspgs on a grand grand scheme of
things and so it leaves the general
architecture of cspgs intact so the
cspgs that are upregulated in the
galicia scar or those that are found
within the perineurium nets will remain
intact we don't see widespread
degradation with treatment of our
compound
now the cspgs may be degraded at the
growing axonal tip because as an axon
grows it needs to remove what's in front
of it cspgs are very dense
molecules very negatively charged and in
order to get through it you need to be
able to break it down and so we do see
some degradation of cspgs as an axon is
growing but only at that growing tip and
so therefore you would only expect to
see cspgs being degraded in the
paranormal net where that axon is
attempting to make the synapse onto the
dendrite or cell body
uh but you are absolutely right the
paraneural net in the adult brain is
protective and it is there to help
solidify those connections
which is fantastic in the adults but not
that fantastic in the injury environment
there was not very strong development or
evolutionary pressure to allow
reorganization of the central nervous
system because up until relatively
recently if you had a cns injury you
were most likely to die because of it
and so there wasn't a long enough period
to for nature to selectively allow
the nervous system to enhance its
plasticity and to regrow those
connections instead what the
nervous system did was double down on
its connections and after an injury the
nervous system is flooded with a lot of
inhibitory molecules and cell types that
can cause additional damage such as a
lot of immune cells
and so what the nervous system does it
upregulates its periodontal net around
those synapses to help maintain the
synapses that it does has but at the
same time it inhibits potential new
connections from occurring
and so what our drug does is like i said
before it doesn't degrade the cspgs that
are upregulated so those will be remain
intact and can still protect the nervous
system
but it does allow axons that do want to
grow and to regenerate to be able to
grow and regenerate through these
inhibitory areas
and another rule that the perineural net
makes is to inhibit connections that are
not meant to be made
and following the innervation a cell
that was innervated but is no longer
de-innervated due to an injury will
release growth factors and other
attracting cues to call axons to
innervate it because it wants to be
re-innervated however the axons that
grow there are unable to re-innervate it
due to the paraneural net inhibiting
those synapses from being made and so
the axons will sit outside the cell body
and never actually make contact with the
neuron itself so our compound allows
those axons to penetrate the paraneural
nets of the neurons that are calling it
and in this way the growth that is
occurring is really guided by the
neurons that were de-innervated and are
requesting for new
connections to be made
now if you go ahead and you degrade all
the cspgs in a given area a lot of the
synapses may become uh less strong and
many more neurons may begin requesting
additional axons and so in the case of
cspg degradation you could get some
ambient sprouting that could actually
lead to non-efficient circuits or in
circuits that could be detrimental
but in our case since we're not causing
widespread degradation and the
innervation is likely occurring due to
cells that are requesting the
innervation to occur it's more directed
than a general
digestion of cspgs or through general
growth factor promoting of regeneration
thank you so much
a couple more questions that we have
time for because nvg 291 promotes growth
could it potentially allow tumors to
grow faster or be carciogenic
it's um so ptp sigma has been identified
in certain
cancers as a tumor suppressor
uh so the answer here is yes um in the
central nervous system oftentimes we
look at cancer research
and try and do the opposite of what
they're doing in some regards uh so for
example uh the the research that has
come around the
p10 pathway and the sox3 pathways which
are very involved in
cancer
also appear to play a large role in the
ability of these cells to regenerate
it's also important to note that our
drug
does not activate or inhibit the
receptor for very long periods of time
and so it's not constantly inhibited but
pgp sigma is known to be
a
step in certain cancers such as
colorectal cancer
to be
mutated prior to
the cancer cells metastasizing or being
able to migrate and so pgp sigma does
seem to be a general regulator of
migration from many different cell types
thank you so much now how will dosing
differ between acute
examples csi
i'm sorry s
ci and chronic example ms or ad
conditions
that's uh good question um so nervous
system damage occurs due to many
different reasons whether it due to
trauma an acute event like spinal cord
injury or due to ongoing disease
processes such as multiple sclerosis and
alzheimer's disease and the needs for
our drugs are likely to be quite
different between the two diseases
now our drug causes the central nervous
system to reorganize itself and so the
changes that occur in the presence of
our drug are expected to persist once
the drug is taken away so in the case of
spinal cord injury we imagine that we
can treat for a finite period of time
and bring about recovery and then we can
stop treatment and that recovery will be
maintained and will no longer be needed
to treat that patient
in the case of multiple sclerosis or
alzheimer's disease it's possible that
we may need to undergo
several different treatment pair
treatment periods for example multiple
sclerosis
multiple sclerosis is one of the
hallmark characteristics is the attacks
that occur that are separated by time
and so
in multiple sclerosis for example we can
envision a treatment paradigm that when
an attack occurs you receive our
compound for a certain amount of time
and they're taken off of it and you
remain off of the compound until another
attack occurs more damage occurs in
which case you can be put back onto our
compound to allow
the uh
repair of the nervous system
dr depaul i want to thank you for this
presentation today and we've had so many
wonderful questions come in do you have
any closing remarks you'd like to
provide our audience before we go today
i just want to thank everybody for this
engaging talk a lot of really great
questions a lot of them that we weren't
able to answer today um but please feel
free to reach out to the company um we
like engaging with the public and with
patients who like to know
how our technology will be used and what
patients uh you know are um are
interested in our technology it helps
really drive the conversation at our
company so
please reach out to us if you want more
information
well i want to thank you again dr depaul
for your time and for your important
research and before we go i want to
thank our audience again for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
and like dr depaul said questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until march 2024 labrits will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
everyone take care and bye
thank you
you